los civiles que están tratando
desesperadamente de salir pero pues no
tienen opciones porque como usted lo
dijo el espacio ya está completamente
cerrado porque pues evidentemente no es
seguro con estos ataques de rusia hacia
ucrania y también pues de forma
terrestre pues hay un caos vehicular muy
grande pero esto esto
de hecho ya se estaba ya se estaba
produciendo salidas de la población de
las grandes ciudades que son
los lugares más sensibles en cuanto a la
población civil pero lo que se está
viendo hasta ahora y posiblemente lo que
vayamos a ver en los próximos días
fundamentalmente es un sistema de
invasión por
ocupación terrestre no se quiere
castigar excesivamente sobre todo no se
quiere atacar de forma general a la
población civil
y quien está a menos de 100 km de la
frontera por bielorrusia y de hecho
utilizando la región de chandler que
está totalmente deshabitada de chernóbil
y uno de los grandes
lagos de miel per se puede llegar
directamente a la capital proveniente de
bielorrusia no se ha querido utilizar
esta medida fundamentalmente lo que se
está en lo que se está buscando es una
ocupación terrestre del este y del sur
de ucrania que son las regiones
rusohablantes que son las regiones donde
el partido de las regiones tenía una
mayoría en las que en principio serían
más asequibles para ocupar de una forma
más pacífica no se va a atacar a la
población lo que se está produciendo
fundamentalmente es un ataque
sistemático de los sistemas militares
para impedir la reacción militar de
ucrania